à nantes à martini bonjour merci d'être
venu aujourd'hui nous rendre visite
vous êtes à vous de la compagnie affable
une compagnie théâtrale et vous êtes ici
pour nous parler de votre spectacle de
la fontaine abouba voilà alors qu'ils
s'y colle au quai de la fontaine
oui bonjour et bien c'est un spectacle
qui va parler de poésie de rap de rythme
on a deux personnages totalement
différent qui s'opposent y en a un qui
est très classique des le texte de
l'auteur et l'autre plus moderne
il va vouloir vulgariser au sens de
rendre accessible à tous donc il va
s'octroyer beaucoup de liberté et ils
sont pas d'accord sur un tas de points
ce qui fait qu'il va y avoir un
éclatement de pleins d'interrogations
sur quel comment on interprète une fable
un texte d'auteur comment le rapport aux
autres au rythme à la poésie et se pose
la question du rap parce que le rap est
il une forme de poésie ou pas très chaud
qu'à la base le rap ça veut dire rythme
et poésie voilà donc c'est forcément la
poésie rien texte qui est qu'ils aient
travaillé donc vous vous jouez classique
l'ancien vous le moderne soir vous avez
repris un peu ce cette querelle
universel et intemporel des anciens et
des modernes pour baser votre spectacle
que vous avez écrit vous même c'est ça
vous valentin bas c'est à dire que moi
j'arrivais avec une première version
d'un spectacle et on va retravailler
ensemble avec guillaume ce spectacle-là
de la fontaine abouba qu'on a qu'on a
écrit à deux et
oui effectivement le principe c'est de
rejouer la dispute des anciens et des
modernes des classiques des modernes
en campant des personnages qui vont
s'attacher chacun de leur côté à quelque
chose de bien spécifique donc comme l'a
dit guillaume mon personnage il sera
peut-être plus attachés au respect de
l'auteur du texte de l'époque etc tandis
que le personnage de guillaume lui sera
plus dans la liberté et la logique de
transmission d'accord parce qu'on parle
de l'idée que la fontaine garde la forme
et restent attachés à la forme et au
fond alors que le rap c'est la liberté
c'est là et finalement on peut dire que
c'est une sorte de richesse puisque on
invente des mots déjà mais mon avant dé
des nouvelles rim ça en russie le vivier
des rimes finalement ce verlan parce que
ça crée des mots qui n'existaient pas et
qui appelle d'autres rim et ça vous le
montrer très bien dans votre texte
qu'est ce que vous pouvez
comment vous avez choisi les fables de
la fontaine que vous comment on a choisi
les fables de la fontaine à tiendra le
corbeau le les prix convenu non non non
mais après c'était une question de
propos qu avec l propos on voulait
défendre le meunier l'année son fils
tombés voilà sous le sens de ce propos
là on avait envie de défendre cette idée
là et puis après d'autres textes
d'autres textes qui justifier notre
notre spectacle et puis les démarches
que ce soit technique ou dans le contenu
dans le fond qu'on voulait exposer quoi
d'accord il fait par choix
en fait c'est une discussion entre deux
copains comme c'est à la terrasse d'un
café
et c'est aussi défense exactement et
c'est la manière dont notre professeur
de théâtre nous a appris à dire une
fable en fait c'est que il faut savoir à
qui on a train de parler ce qu'on est en
train d'essayer de lui dire et on va
utiliser une petite histoire en
l'occurrence une fable au début du
spectacle pour le convaincre le
persuader et du coup le choix des textes
est venu comme ça au fur et à mesure que
le propos avance une réponse qui évolue
actuellement principe du spectacle c'est
que la discussion évolué et qu'à chaque
fois on va utiliser une illustration
textuel musicales théâtrales pour
appuyer le propos
voilà et puis pour que ça reste aussi
léger c'est parce que c'est une comédie
c'est très drôle on rigole on espère oui
mais je vous dis les gens rient on rit
du début à la fin
bon bah super donc vous vous êtes dit on
qu'on va créer ce spectacle pour
pourquoi pour donner le goût des mots
pour entre autres où il eu l'idée c'est
que ces deux copains là ils viennent sur
le plateau parce qu'ils ont un amour
commun du théâtre et de la poésie
d'accord du texte bon et ça va
s'exprimer dans des formes différentes
dans leur style parce que c'est un
spectacle que vous destinez comme les
mosans aux collégiens ou lycéens bas le
10 on le destine à personne en pratique
on a eu le spectre fin l'objectif c'est
que ce soit un spectacle rassembleur
grand public une vraie comédie qui fait
rire à la fois les petits les les
anciens et les modernes et caetera et
quelle que soit l'origine sociale des
personnes qui viennent dans la salle
parce que ça c'est un truc qu'on a
constatée au festival d'avignon oui vous
étiez au on est tu vas le d'avignon
l'été et on a eu des gens de deux
d'extraction plutôt humble des gens de
catégories sociales plutôt aisés qui
chacun à trouver quelque chose de
positif ou quelque chose qui lui parlait
dans le spectacle et du coup ça c'est en
d'esprit qu'on a envie de conserver
d'avoir ce côté rassembleur comme ça le
temps d'une représentation génial locaux
de l'aspect fédérateur de ce spectacle
est génial parce que finalement leur le
rap a quand même une mauvaise réputation
dans certains milieux est ce qu'on peut
dire qu'il existe deux sortes de rap à
savoir un rap un peu violent vulgaire
agressif misogyne et un rap plus plus
poétique vous serez les artistes ont
vécu aussi de ce qu'ils ont envie de
raconter un rap teinté de violence c'est
un rap qui
catharsique voilà un rapt politique
comment oui qui viennent leur vécu qui
viennent leur vécu qui vient leur vécu
ils témoignent comme ça avec du rythme
et des mots et puis un instrumental et
puis voilà le rap poétique
c'est aussi ça dépend je pense que c'est
conditionnelle de la situation de
l'artiste pas d'accord ouais t'as son
faut pas se leurrer ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il ya énormément de clichés sur leurs
appuis il ya beaucoup de pression et les
tifs exactement
et nous ce qu'on essaye de dire c'est
que au milieu des rappeurs tout comme un
milieu des écrivains des journalistes
des sportifs des artistes etc
il ya toujours à boire et à manger il ya
toujours des gens qui qui ont comme on
dire des valeurs différentes et une
notion de leur travail qui peut qui peut
diverger et du coup dans le rap en tout
cas il ya une essence poétique qui
indubitablement ce que déjà en anglais
comme on disait women poetry donc le
rythme et la poésie le en anglais brahim
ming wrapping donc rimer et râper c'est
complètement synonyme donc l'idée de
rythme et de rim s'est complètement
consubstantielle au rap
alors après il ya des choses qui
divergent complètement de la culture
classique il ya des choses qui peuvent
choquer parce que ça peut être une
poésie violente les ya des messages qui
sont violents dans le rap mais je pense
que c'est intéressant d'aller creuser et
devoirs aux épargnants oui de voir le
ski comment dire les parallèles qu'on
peut faire entre classique et moderne et
puis aussi les innovations du rap le par
exemple verlan c'en est une
alors ça vient pas que du rap mais en
tout cas ils se l'approprient et le
verlan ça permet de multiplier les rimes
par 2 par 3 par quatre du verlan donc ça
permet une vraie innovation l'après
nouveautés sur la création ce mais c'est
aussi assez démocratique parce que tout
le monde peut faire du rap
y a pas besoin de moyens techniques a
pas besoin d'écoles particulière c'est
un peu là pour tout le monde non ballard
en général quand on peut tous perdre on
est bien sûr mais celui-là malheureux
particulièrement et moi on n'est pas des
roms on n'est pas des rappeurs alors je
ne sais pas comment tout le monde il
faut avoir une ou rivés sur cas voilà
oui effectivement c'est accessible bien
sûr accessible à bien sûr en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que c'est la forme de
poésie contemporaine la plus
accessible et la plus aimée des français
puisque le rap c'est le genre musical
préféré des français depuis 15 ans
maintenant
donc quand on voit des jeunes dans la
rue qui sont en train de répéter des
paroles de rap et ben il faut pas dire
ok ils sont en train de s'attacher un
objet culturel ou pseudo culturel pour
les plus sceptiques violent non c'est
aussi une forme de poésie et il y a une
comme on dire il ya une âme ur du
langage parce qu'ils recherchent
complètement une recherche dans le texte
des jeux nous mourrons sa crise et
figures de style etc ça ah bon ça
pullule dans le rap on est donc il faut
pas voir ça d'un point de vue négatif je
pense au contraire ça montre parce que
le rap c'est quand même un genre où le
l'instrumental qui est derrière ces
quelque chose de musicalement simple
donc il ya du texte
il ya vraiment le texte est très
important et donc le fait qu'ils aient
autant de jeunes qui s'intéressent à des
paroles en français comme ça au texte il
ya de la poésie
je pense que c'est plutôt positif le
message qu'on essaie de faire passer
dans le spectacle c'est que c'est un peu
comme monsieur jourdain qui fait de la
prose sans le savoir mais pour le coup
ce les fans de rap
ils font de la poésie sans le savoir ça
va nous annoncer un des messages qu'on
essaie de passer d'accord alors où est
ce qu'on peut vous voir là vous allez
jouer où quand comment
votre spectacle va partir en tournée à
là on a on a pas d'actualité
on a des dates mais dans des
établissements scolaires louis classe on
va jouer plutôt pour lisser parce que
car comme cd comment dire les
thématiques du spectacle elles elles
répondent plutôt programme de du lycée
la française français ouais le bac de
français donc seconde première et oui
parce qu'on a été j'avais été appelé par
des professeurs de français
exactement installe but du jeu on va la
faire notre mission dans les
établissements c'est trop bien
exactement
on aimait france en dordogne on a des
gens qui veulent devenir dauphin qui
veulent qu'on vienne dans leur lycée à
marseille et c'est donc pour l'instant
il faut que j'analyse tout ça mais donc
il ya des petites communes avaient été
tous par ci par là commence à en avoir
marre et que ce que vous avez joué
plusieurs dates à la royale factory à
versailles exactement
et donc c'est parti de là et d'avignon
comme vous le dit tout à l'heure vous
avez d'autres projets sinon de deux
seuls en scène où on en parle c'est pas
prêt pas prêt du tout à me classer en
écriture tiens vous semez votre voilà
d'acteurs et donc vous avez des bronzés
qu à la fois des professeurs et des
élèves et
génial ben pense que c'est un spectacle
et une longue vie devant lui et qu à un
message salutaire au moment justement on
arrive dans une période un peu spécial
compliqué ouais avec les élections etc
ou les discours politiques vont utiliser
tel ou tel message dans un sens ou dans
l'autre et nous on a juste une logique
de de rassembler le temps d'une
représentation les gens autour du
théâtre et de la poésie
voilà c'est notre sol a changé le regard
exactement et que ce soit d'un côté ou
de l'autre parce que ce soit les jeunes
sur les classiques ou les anciens sur
les modèles justement parce que quand
vous commencez le spectacle vous vous
commencé à réciter la fable de l'eau
c'est le livre une escale à douala est
prononcée lourd
ah mais non c'est toi c'est celle
d'après pardon et c'est assez drôle et
donc ça peut rebuter ses mots ce
vocabulaire du xviie et c'est donc vous
prenez aussi bien sur le tour gardons
ces nouveautés aussi et tout comme le
verlan ou même le champ lexical qu'on
peut trouver dans des chansons de rap je
vois par exemple le groupe et nl ils ont
un vocabulaire bien à eux qui vient de
la cité même de l'univers du deal et c
est
bah ça c'est pareil aussi il faut il
faut décoder il faut donner les codes
pour les gens pour qu'on voie un peu
qu'elle rêve de quelle réalité son sens
de nous parler alors vous êtes immergés
dans une bande de rappeurs pour acquérir
toutes ses connaissances ou non c'est
juste en écoutant non c'est en écoutant
puis c'est notre mai au parcours
personnel moi je sais que j'ai toujours
aimé le rabbin pas toujours mais mais en
tout cas j'en ai écouté j'en écoute
toujours
et voilà mais c'est du goût personnel
des corps et puis le rire la musique
quoi j'aime la musique et puis le
terrain le rappeur ça y est c'est pas
une école encore très très puissante
il ya plutôt d'autres styles de musique
mais n'ira lui même il y en a il y en a
mais c'est pas dans le même genre enfin
s'il ya comment il s'appelle fuzati wii
qui vient qui vient de versailles et
pour le coup donc un flow assez monotone
après quoi le flou ont terminé mais le
flou c'est un mélange de
respiration c'est à dire de là où on va
moins peur on va placer sa respiration
dans le texte est aussi sur le rythme et
puis après on peut rajouter aussi des
dimensions de simplement de grain de
voix ou des choses comme ça c'est un
mélange c'est pas une notion très très
clair mais en gros des pâtes on va dire
le spectacle mon personnage ont fait
plus ou moins un concept duflot il dit
le flou c'est la liberté c'est à dire
c'est un élan spontané quoi origines et
voilà personnel savait pas être
quelqu'un dos et irremplaçable donc
c'est très personnel c'est la com qui
voient encore plus que la voix quoi
c'est la voix leur manière de l'arrivée
le voilà c'est l'âme c'est
l'interprétation voilà avec ce mot
interprétation singulière l'on remercie
avec plaisir la merci et à très vite
j'espère vraiment recommande votre
spectacle qui est merci mme intéressant
et drôle
merci merci merci à vous